gang christmas came early this year
cause the are you garbage special is on
youtube right now yeah guys go share
with your friends hit them up in the
group chat tell people who aren't
familiar with the show this is a perfect
way to introduce them check it out it's
a good time a lot of laughs thanks for
watching love you welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is the christmas
episode ho ho ho not talking about your
mom either i'm your host dave foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at aunt tony's basement she's
upstairs cranking out homemade eggnog
it's like boardwalk empire bathtub gin
trucks going in and out all night
[ __ ] tommy guns laying around aunt
lucky
[Laughter]
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table dressed loudly for the
holidays this is a new me
this is kj baby
that kippy's old news this is all kg you
have zany uncle ruined christmas for
getting a dui on christmas eve vibes
right now i have i have i have uncle who
gets handsy vibes
i'm gonna wrestle the teenagers you know
what i mean
who just finished their freshman year at
college
shout out to uncle larry gang it's the
holidays give it up for our father
kevin james ryan hey gang what's up
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate me if you subscribe
on itunes
full video available on youtube as you
know those numbers are true to roof true
the [ __ ]
oh boy i think there's a new special or
something i heard over there we got a
hot new special hot new special summer
saying the best special 2021 i don't
know i don't know what you're talking
about but it's over there check out the
[ __ ] ayg special on the youtube page
most of you probably already seen it
share with a pal share with a friend and
then also it's that time of year it's a
giving season uh-huh you know what i
mean like patreon.com patreon.com like
to give thanks and praise to sam yam and
jack conte their whole families i hope
they're safe and during this uptick in
kovitz yeah they got real trees they got
real cut fresh cut down they probably
got probably like 12 footers in there
douglas first let's get them 14 footers
next year gang sign up for the patreon
couple of frasier furs a lot of uh a lot
of presents under that tree over there
billions of hours of content check it
out we love yous we appreciate everybody
love you sharing the specials you've
done this has been an amazing year for
us thank you so [ __ ] much and the
army of garbage has really rallied
around the special and you're all
sharing it and we [ __ ] can't thank
you enough
we love yous
we're here we're family quick shout out
the hell
to who to who the [ __ ] rock star of
the day the magic man what do you see oh
no you don't [ __ ] together
the genius
t-bone mcscruffins toby mcmullen oh yeah
what up dudes what up t-bone nothing if
i don't get a goddamn red bull
sponsorship out of the amount of
sugar-free red bulls i've been cranking
the past couple days it's cooking
thanks for watching guys we [ __ ] love
you yes we do we love you guys we're
here for the christmas episode uh-huh
which is great because it's going to be
out right [ __ ] before christmas it's
very christmassy that's the idea we're
not going to drop it on july 4th you
[ __ ] idiot it's a christmas special
it's coming out two days before
christmas by easter but that's nice i
always liked when i was a kid
the christmas specials that would come
out right around christmas yeah like
sometimes they would screw you like
you'd get like two weeks before
christmas not to say i want it right
there december december 15th it kicks in
for me you're crazy you're crazy i want
the whole season i start christmas after
thanksgiving yeah it's stupid i mean it
was like [ __ ] 65 degrees in new york
this year i picked out my tree wearing
shorts what are we doing
i'll take my ambrosia and go home
please get that [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
face were you in were you an eggnog
family no we were we were a nutty irish
drunken fighter yeah we were
the drinks called
it's hard to have christmas with no
one's speaking to each other huh
well there were certain years where some
people were dry which was better off for
everybody uh no we were a big nutty
irishman family which is what uh it's
like uh
frangelica dude notre dame footballs
of headlocks
and i write waggle uh no it's like
frangelica bailey's and maybe uh like
amaretto or something dude what is it
with garbage that i meant bailey
my family would talk about bailey's dude
my my aunt patty would on chris so this
was the start of the season it was
thanksgiving everybody went to everybody
went to paddy's at the end of
thanksgiving you met patty i know patty
yeah firecracker that patty she's a
little spark plug that way i tell you
so you don't take no guff we'd all go to
paddy's
for like dessert and call everybody had
their own dinner or whatever everybody
would meet a patty coffee desserts the
whole and we picked the pollyanna for
christmas all the kids would pick the
pollyanna same thing same exact thing
it's crazy but they would you the season
for me started when they came out with a
waterford crystal pitcher a nutty
irishman i don't know it was waterproof
it might have been off the back of a
truck
but
it was a mixing do that
as a punch bowl
i mean
as a kid this thing was like fifty
thousand dollars in my head i've never
seen a glass pitcher in my life that
didn't have fruit punch stains on it
uh if it wasn't powdered iced tea i
wasn't [ __ ] with it but they used to
come around with this and i remember
being like wait till i get my hands on
that i was like
six-year-old
i want that [ __ ] ha ha juice the
adults are drinking a little scratch it
nutmeg on there [ __ ] set me straight
come out with ice and they would pour it
nutty irishman i love that that was big
for us i wanted to do something today
but we have a very busy day yes we do we
have a very busy deal your presence to
give we have questions to get to we have
goddamn christmas to celebrate here
shout out to the holiday season baby
shout out to all the jewish people out
there happy holidays
i celebrated with my wife and my in-laws
this uh this season very nice did you
via zoom yeah we let the candles
youngest guy in the family's gotta like
the candles i lit the candles i got an
old bar i got an old bird are you the
youngest
in the household really me and my wife
yeah you lit the candle you didn't [ __ ]
it up did you no goddamn jesus christ
i'm blowing it out making a wish
you got it in a sheet cake
these better not be trick candles all
right
fool me once
it's just those sparklers like in clubs
when they bring the bottles out bottle
of grey bottle of nutty irishman please
what'd you get for hanukkah anything
nothing they don't do that they they
it's like uh i don't think they do it
it's more of like just a they do it just
like one dinner
one night typically you know what i mean
like they're not doing like day crazy
nights the presents i can't underst it's
i just i don't think this is bread in me
from being catholic and a dirt bag and
and just selfish all the time sure but
if there was a holiday out there uh-huh
that that where presents were given out
uh-huh there's no way i'm not [ __ ]
getting involved in that what do you
mean like there's no way even even if i
was jewish i would still i would i would
first of all know hanukkah presents come
on what are we doing here i'm saying as
adults yeah whatever as kids they did
yes kids they did it but i'm saying now
as adults it's like
i don't want to open up eight shitty
presents ah eight different times ah
sucks great oh
oh keychain ah no way oh i love new
socks i like getting new stocks to do
one of these yeah well
a little something i don't know i'm
saying as an adult i don't want to do
you know i don't want to do that did you
get the ladies something for christmas i
did yeah i can't say because this is
coming out before
but also
it's
they're it's getting delivered today oh
and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um
and it came with an ottoman
a little table okay um
i was a kevin james joke from back in
the day who wrote a piece and went oh
ottomans or you buy a jack or you buy
electronics and it comes with the little
packets who who buys a tv going oh cool
came with chiclets because it says do
not eat whatever um guys for more of
that comedy check out uh 2002's kevin j
what was that now let's go back to that
insult that never got off the [ __ ]
runway um captain got hijacked
take me to cuba
um
i got it delivered but it's like she's
gonna see it she's gonna know she's got
a sign you know so it's like it's the
cat's problem by the time this airs in
tomorrow or whatever the cat's probably
out of the bag but i just was like yo
don't look at the [ __ ] box never no
cats are ever out of the bag it's
secrecy that was always my house it was
always about the show
the presents were usually set up
downstairs of course you know what i
mean like weird if you're bringing them
out of the trunk
in the morning yeah they're set up
downstairs then there was one hidden
somewhere oh yeah they'll go look under
the couch but we had to wait i couldn't
go rushing down there at six o'clock
daddy be all over course of course i had
to make sure i had my good pajamas on
she'd comb out my hair i my brother my
brother couldn't wait my brother's you
know
ants in the pants
i wouldn't sleep at all first of all he
would go down he'd go down at like 6 a.m
and do some recon you know what i mean
he'd he'd be like down there in a gilly
suit night vision goggles yeah it'd be
like mission impossible
not [ __ ] touching anything
he'll cut he'd come up he'd be like i
saw a helmet something's big down a bike
some big's coming down a pike
oh it's a go-kart a bike a moped
somebody's getting something with them
wheels on it though
yeah i'm sorry did you guys ever uh find
the secret stash before christmas yeah
me and my brother i think it was starter
jackets or something and i didn't know
and i just listened to him he was a
little pricked that one so he went up
and he found jackets
and we came down if i recall in the
jackets on like december 3rd you idiot i
didn't know i was like oh he's doing it
i mean he's an [ __ ] yeah well he came
down we're like yo what up my mom that
was a tough [ __ ]
it was like one of the early christmases
after the divorce she was she was like
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] ruin a [ __ ]
surprise ah yeah the only thing better
than christmas ruining christmas
eve one time oh the piece dropped the
f-bomb on the way to my aunt karen's
nice and it was like it was like oh we
all cause she don't curse that much
really and she dropped she dropped you
[ __ ] in grazers yeah that's what i
liked and it was like the record stop we
were all like i'm so sorry i'll go to
mass right now i apologize go put five
dollars in a four bucks
i make some presents the next day when
everybody makes up it's like family
makeup sex that's nice oh man you are so
[ __ ] up it's not even funny we legit
ruined multiple christmases i had to
have talked about this last year but one
year my mom's [ __ ] slaving working my
dad's traveling she wraps up all the
presents she puts them in the dining
room um she goes out to work one night
i'm sitting there watching tv my brother
walks in he's probably 13 i'm 11. he
walks in holding a brand new shoe how
much one shoe sneaker like just show me
you know what i mean i'm like what the
[ __ ] was that he's like come here he
figured out what goods figured out a way
to take a razor blade and cut the tape
and slide everything out [ __ ]
sneakers this that
sega genesis that i've been wanting
all this stuff the whole nine yards we
literally we had two christmases we were
in there we were making popcorn [ __ ]
eggnog looking through everything where
she was gone yeah put everything back
real slick right
that christmas is where you caught the
acting bug
oh my god new shoes
mother how did you know i knew then it
was next for broadway
you light a sick yeah i like sneakers
oh my god sneakers
how will i go on
i do declare
um a couple days later my mom notices
this obviously we get home from school
my dad's home at the time he was working
about 400 miles away he usually didn't
come back until friday yeah it's like a
wednesday he's there at four o'clock
all right we're done yeah something's up
your mother's over at your aunt
colleen's balling her eyes out he's
[ __ ] ruined christmas you're done
he's like did you take your panties
and [ __ ] dude they [ __ ] with us for
like three weeks
christmas morning chinese water torture
whatever
[Laughter]
you're like
what's going on here hey red your
fingernails pulled out by your mother um
put like long dirty laundry in all the
boxes
[ __ ] with the said i didn't get this
didn't get that yada yada like just
legit like that's why i look back and
i'm like how did you stay in this yeah
we were [ __ ] brutal oh yeah i think
it was a different time
it was the 20s for crying out loud
everything was in black and white we
didn't know what was happening
goddamn kaiser was on the move
very trashy yeah um but let's we'll
let's say let's hop into it let's just
exchange your gifts let's do it i mean
foley first of all i heard you've been
you've been poking around some of my
personal friends how do you know that
cause i was talking to one of them and
he goes defolie give you your gift i
don't know what it is he goes to fully
give you your gift yet i said he would
you remember he's been outsourcing this
oh yeah i do my research
i like to know who i'm in business with
also and then it was like i didn't know
you had a condo in boca i'll tell you
that we were in here like all [ __ ]
getting ready and everything the special
just all [ __ ] working if you can see
behind foley he's made a he's made a
false wall
of [ __ ] wrapping paper to hide my
gift which i don't know what it is
i don't know i kept this thing alive all
these weeks
it's rattling like jurassic park you
just see the leaves are out on the
ground
[ __ ] crane comes up half a toby yeah i
did some snooping right he shouldn't
have said anything flip keep it zipped
yeah shout out to flip shout out to flip
uh all right so how do you want to do
this well first of all we should say
thank you so much for all the support
last year we couldn't even afford gift
snacks also that's also pretty crazy i
wanted to yeah a year ago just to show
how [ __ ] awesome the army guard does
all the [ __ ] support how like last
year
to decorate this and i think we bought
toby hot wheels was toby's gift oh yeah
that's right then i bought them faster
than furious i bought them out to dwayne
reed around the corner
and i had 80 in my personal bank account
and i spent 60
to decorate the same lights it's this
yeah and the you know and to get toby
hot wheels now i think toby's gonna like
his presence a little bit better now the
kids are a little flushed
he's got a little bit of cash on him i
mean the man's wearing a 3 000 suit
i am returning it
if the irs is is
this will be returned when you were a
kid you knew which christmases were the
good ones when you went when you had a
couple to look them over what do you
mean you knew one you knew when things
were flush oh and things were er well i
had the i had the mom i had the two
different christmases so i had that my
dad was always going heavy my dad was
like here's the bb gun here's the mini
bike dan he's got a go-cart he was
really you know vying for uh
for the start is that me
no it's not
okay oh this is crazy all right how do
you want to do this you want to give
t-bone first like you said we're the
parents we got to give t-bone yes we
give t-bone as gifts first okay well
then i have to i'm going to eat about
t-bone
t-bone bring it to come over and sit
with us bring your phone over t-bone i
got to email you your present
what the [ __ ] what do you mean
i'll get you something else today we'll
go to the store
the kid's gonna have something to open
he will relax and yeah an email
why do you guys [ __ ] on the president
why not just [ __ ] roll with it you
[ __ ] fat idiot yeah there we go come
on
yeah you can you only operate in chaos
that's crazy if everybody's happy look
how nervous he is on camera
i'm wearing this shitty sweater
it really feels like christmas
put the t-shirt on it looked like you
just came down from christmas morning
yeah i got sweatpants on you're our
dirtbag son home from college
oh man the comments would be light and
t-boned off oh this sucks ass all right
let's do it all right i'll t-bone open
up your email okay this is a two-part
this is a two-part or a one-part gift
okay
it's an
invoice i owe you three thousand dollars
hey tough the [ __ ]
uh
vamp the [ __ ] ain't this [ __ ] it's not
refreshing
hey t-bone cut this out
all right i can just show you too oh
here we go oh
hang on thank you for purchasing tickets
for pup oh you got me popcorn tickets to
his favorite band in new york city
and the day off oh my god thank you so
much how many tickets two tickets two
tickets which means i now have six
tickets to that show
shoot it into star after a loser who
needs two i'm selling
and why do you get two then he's gotta
choose between me or you who goes you
weren't gonna go i'd have never even
heard of these boys
i would go if there was if it was only
one ticket left and you were going to go
i bought four tickets so that we the
three of us could go and bring why don't
you say something i thought that's not
our present is it what no good
i also got you tickets to see my
favorite band
what the [ __ ]
well now you don't have the night off
you're working
t-bone really [ __ ] up that rules thank
you man thank you yeah mine came with a
card okay
okay all right let's do it that's for
you thank you merry christmas and i love
you oh i love you guys too and great job
on the [ __ ] on the special killing it
you killed it
making it funny
my headphones are going out that really
is annoying
uh wishing you a joyous season
t-bone for when you can't sleep love you
pal i'm gonna take a picture i like this
video i got like i mean i like this
right now toby did a very foley thing it
was imperative that you read the card
out loud you have to you had to read the
card out loud well it's an audio video
medium yeah they can't exactly
be a bad clip i meant just in general
when i was a kid oh my god what you got
me a
it's a willard it only plays one game
kill the americans oh my god thank you
foley you're welcome buddy holy [ __ ] i
figure cause you had said that you were
having trouble sleeping yes um and i
said you know what do you have what do
you have in the room with you you said i
take my phone in there sometimes i'll
take a tablet so now you don't have to
sit on the couch you can you can lay in
there and play your games until you uh
until you fall asleep thank you so much
i didn't get you any games
because these things you download them
these days and i figure
star wars spider-man i don't want to
impose that on you so you get what you
want um and it's the oled so it can hook
up to the tv oh my thank you so much
dude you're very welcome my god thank
you guys that's [ __ ] very thoughtful
of course so much i have one more like
stocking stuffer type john oh six oh
yeah i mean this is just something
little that we thought to give thousand
dollars cash baby let's go
i feel like supreme patty
okay this money let's go we're doing
christmas this year it's legitimately
filthy
i asked for the smallest bills they had
they said this has been shout out to
frank's check cash you know 30.
holy [ __ ] look at that
and eighty dollars
also we might have to borrow 200 to tip
the door oh
[Music]
little cash for at the moment holy [ __ ]
thank you go down there going down to
north carolina see your family gonna
have a good time
take the old brought out to an outback
or something like that thank you guys so
much of course buddy can i give you guys
your presents yeah okay better better be
a thousand dollars
just break something
you guys stop sit in your
pocket oh my god
you did a great job this year buddy we
appreciate you we love you thank you i
love you guys all right let me grab your
[ __ ] hang on yeah yeah
look at that huh long hair maybe he'll
turn out to be all right afterwards
that belongs in a house buster
bespoke post baby love best boxers
awesome not summer not fall what it is
right now
winter probably nice little goodies in
there they got you all lined up baby
they're making moves too i saw i saw a
commercial for them on on the old tv
really oh yeah they're real quality
stuff nice
they know what they're doing they got
your winter cocktails cozy threads
camping gear essentials whatever you
need box of awesome has collections for
every part of your life they were nice
enough to send us a box i got we got a
duffel bag we got hammocks we got pants
we got [ __ ] i got a cool knife that
opened up all my pop my back my boxes
with i feel like crocodile dundee little
martini shaker
[ __ ] awesome
to get started just go to box of
awesome.com take the two minute quiz uh
they're going to line you up with the
best category for you
um they release new boxes every month
tons of different categories it's free
to sign up you can skip a month or
cancel at any time each box only costs
45 bucks and has over 70 worth of gear
inside that's free money uh plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business 90 of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand
so here you go baby get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and our promo code
garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome.com promo garbage for 20 bucks
for 20 off your first box do it
gang this podcast is brought to you by
the good people and better help better
help wants to help if you got something
that's going on you want to talk it out
with somebody you can do it from the
privacy the comfort and the sanctuary
that is your own home it's not a
self-help belonging it's not a crisis
line it's licensed professional
therapists that are there to help you
yeah guys services available worldwide
and they're committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
need be it's more affordable than
traditional offline care and financial
available financial aid is available uh
if need be
um we're gonna help you out
they're trying to help or bill we're
both big proponents of mental health you
just started uh seeing somebody i've
seen somebody in the past for a long
time i'm real crazy it's great i mean
we're two we're bonkers as it is
goofballs i'll let you get your you let
you get an understanding of where you're
coming who you are where everything you
know and we said it's a pain in the ass
to try to find a specialist in your area
whatever you need sometimes wherever you
live
better help
it's an easy way
it's an easy way into the pool too if
you're on if you're on the fence about
it sign up online easy peasy you don't
have to leave your house so special
offer for all you are you garbage
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com garbage uh one
more time get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com garbage
also between gifts like when you're
doing gifts what do you guys do with the
you have the trash bag for the for the
wrapping paper we had to go [ __ ] back
and forth andrew me everything was laid
out oh we did all once kevin you that's
what we do now what kevin you go so i
gotta sit there like a jerk off for 25
minutes while you open [ __ ] 25 minutes
what is this jesus christ
i hope it's blonde huh
until we got us a stinger missile
everywhere
what are we supposed to do with this
open it
who's is it it's both of yours oh boy so
you want us to open it
no i want you to [ __ ] what yeah okay
you can you can do the honor where's the
throat slitter
uh i think it's in the i think it's in
the cat i think it's in the closet dudes
thank you so much that's so [ __ ]
awesome
switch is nice huh
yeah the key ain't too shabby neither
all right
kippy slices open all right so this is
this will be it this will be real nice
especially because you're blocking the
camera especially for the people who are
on the patreon they'll [ __ ] get it
is it a huge chicken sandwich oh my god
it's so funny what is chicken sandwiches
all right foley opens the box nothing
everybody shut up
all right foley opens the box
and inside what are we supposed to share
all right a bunch of wrapping paper
comes out
holy [ __ ] that's a lot of paper
what do we got what are we doing here i
hope it's tiny
i got you [ __ ] i got you [ __ ] sound
bars because you idiots are using iphone
speakers on your [ __ ] kids guys
electronics very nice i mean buttons got
to get you some buttons right that's
great
sweet
kippy recently if you're not on the
patreon kitty recently got his first tv
like a goddamn adult
i'm a tv boy if you're li if you're if
you have a tv and you're using the tv
speakers you're an [ __ ] because it
sounds like [ __ ] so now you got a
[ __ ] nice quality image with some
quality sound come on yeah that's what
i'm talking about that's [ __ ] sick
dude
beautiful at that
nice
gotta display that i literally ordered
it during the episode i was like you
have a sound board you were like my
voice is crackling a child and you were
like you're like no i don't got one of
them foley wasn't either and i was like
[ __ ] easy does it here we go
also shout out brilliant i would have
never guessed that shout out keep it
going for a second shout out to the
expedited shipping i paid which doubled
the cost of the gift
and then we did it and then
extra weeks and then i got covered and
we had we
yeah
uh that's great mary [ __ ] christmas
guys thank you buddy this is [ __ ]
amazing
this is so good so far
gotta love gotta love christmas
t-bone's walking out a little bit of
cash t-bone you better take an uber home
don't be getting jacked i'm saying bro
all right so now you want to go
you give me give me give me give me
i kind of i threw you with the a little
stocking stuffer you really didn't hit
on where the g huh
shout out to a g bar you know what i
mean hell yeah
let's go talk about things sounding
better all right i didn't wrap anything
because i i'm garbage and whatever it is
what it is my wife was even like i'll
wrap that i'm like no it's fine but you
know
but um here you go
it's 300 bucks beautiful
ah you got me a watch or did it
it's a black mamba
you start kicking around
[Laughter]
oh man thank you it's a nice one too a
promaster
oh look at this thing i put my weed in
there
this is beautiful buddy
oh man that's [ __ ] nice
you're a big watch guy you're always
breaking them i'm a big watch guy this
is absolutely beautiful we're also going
to take what's uh what's the over under
on how long do you think it lasts i got
the rubber band because you're a big the
bands the bands the pins pop out on you
yeah it's all good it's beautiful it's
[ __ ] absolutely beautiful put mine in
here put this on right now
this is absolutely fantastic
thank you citizens of my brand too
you're a big city i was jumping back and
i was on a rolex player maybe next year
that might be next year you went to the
page yeah i would have dropped it i
would have dropped a you know it's not
money it's not money it's i was trying
to find one that you would like i think
that's subtle enough you know it's
perfect i love it it's not enough i
still think it's you know it's nice
classy
it's like sporty but still whatever
very beautiful thank you so much look at
that new watch t-bone
look at that right there looks good on
me
[ __ ] beautiful i love it i honestly
absolutely love it thank you buddy thank
you pal beautiful
look at that huh christmas ah this is my
favorite episode
[Laughter]
new guy luke who got you some more
patreon episodes
yeah
i'll continue to pay you
this is gorgeous thank you honestly
i [ __ ] i love it
i absolutely love it give me the [ __ ]
bird or whatever you got me
i'm dreading this putting a lot of old
newspaper at your house
here's your card
read it aloud i will not yes you have to
i think you said your goal was to make
me cry that was my goal to make t-bone
cry so funny you both had goals to make
each other cry this week yeah neither
one succeeded no toby got me with the
salmon cotton from the kwanzaa what the
[ __ ]
papers from my lawyer
[Laughter]
i'm sure you've been served
i'm suing for more control of the
podcast
i want to do the clips
give me the instagram paste words now
you're dead meat
wishing you a joyous season you have
done so much for us i wanted
i want you
i want to you
i don't show you a couple of trips to
living certainly so god damn it i wanted
to use something just give me it i'll
read it no i i want it to you i wanted
to give you you don't have give in there
hey i will though this guy stinks i'm
gonna take it back what the [ __ ] i
wanted to use something i got the a.d.d
you gotta write cards with magazine
clippings like a serial killer dude
first of all
you write like a doctor who's getting
high on his own supply
this is the fully speaking
merry good merry christmas 12 s's and
christmas
can i read it please i'll read it i'm
trying to read it you might not be able
to see how insane you are you write a
card for me and want to read the card
well i wanted to express the this the
sentiment is not being started with a
[Laughter]
yeah from now on you write cards and
pencils i mean jesus christ you're
breaking my stones you forgot words
dictated but the whole thing's nine
words and you lost you forgot three i
love my watch you have done so much for
us i wanted to give you something just
for you you gave me a future here is a
piece of the past best boss i ever had
best friend i could ask for love you
who frank [ __ ] is frank he said that
because you're about to start crying no
i wasn't no get you what do you think
you would have to do to get me
you need a blowtorch to get me to cry
and my pants down okay i'm i'm [ __ ]
dead i tried to get your dad to show up
he looked at the patreon numbers it
wasn't budget
he said get a couple more zeros behind
that fatty maybe i'll pop by yeah all
right so do i open to your show do you
unveil you you you go over you and
without looking over the top okay rip
down and unveil yeah okay
well cut to a commercial or something
all right you got to stay on mike
i'm gonna stay on mic don't look move
move that first
i hope you like it
yes now listen before you open it um
like i said something you know it's like
it's like what do i get the guy that
does everything for me that that you
know that that has everything that's
doing everything how about a g bar
this guy got us a blacklight what the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
i wanted something for you if you wanted
to sit and relax and unwind you have a
drink do your thing whatever he got you
an opium addiction
here we go i'm good yes
oh yeah
and i'll be dropping the receipt on the
floor later by accident
that is a gretch short fret bass guitar
with fender amplifier strap you have a
there's a case over there for it you
have extra strings you have everything
you need and you can sit and you can you
know you get
sit and you can have a drink and you can
play your base
huh i'm kidding this is great thank you
so much you played the bass in your band
that's why i got it for you he plays the
bass
thank you so much i'm sure this is
fantastic
well
thank you place us on
this thing tuned or i can't thank you so
much thank god
thank you it's great i love you i
figured you'd dig it right yeah
and if not give it to your nephew or
something
yeah or whoever
yeah maybe it stays in here who knows
maybe it just works on the set yeah
[Laughter]
maybe it lives in the car i don't know
maybe there's a pawn shop two blocks
away
if i go downstairs and find one of the
doorman
planes fight your stairway to heaven
taking the baseline for a walk
you guys got flea working here what's
going on yeah that's funny thank you so
much that's great that's very thoughtful
it's a gretch baby gretch guitar
thank you that's awesome you're welcome
what if whatever what a merry christmas
we're having when we were talking about
what foley was going to get you
we were like we were having a discussion
about you as a human being and we were
like kippy needs a hobby dude he needs
something to [ __ ] cool his brain off
never
yeah and i figured since you played you
know you play you played in abandon in
high school you know how to play the
bass sure you'd sit there and sound dude
it sounds awesome you're gonna love it
thank you yeah it's really good the only
thing i didn't get you was headphones
because i didn't really know what you'd
like
so
i know you got the broad downstairs
busting your balls
put the headphones on on a sunday
sitting out of your scotch play a little
bit on something for you to unwind sure
i appreciate that yeah yeah yeah i'm
just also waiting for you to be like oh
i also got a guitar i'm trying to get
the band back
next thing you know i'm playing backup
and foley in the bozos or something
i mean i just i'm gonna lead bozo i just
want to say in here i have some lyrics
that i think you'll really
really really care about sunny day sunny
day
yes thank you that's awesome merry
christmas to everybody merry christmas
to everybody
we love you that's great now i mean the
the homies on it at their patreon wrote
in they got a bunch of christmas stuff
they want to get into um guys so as you
know when you join a patreon we will
answer your garbage questions stories
whatever it is uh we got you as a humble
christmas is a big crux of this show the
holiday season you set the time on this
i don't think so okay what time is it
right now
i think that's like an off-air thing we
can do is we're trying to
i mean that's insane hey man you just
stopped me from broadcasting the show to
ask me if i set the time and then what
time was it like we're not in the middle
of the show i'm getting christmas
morning fully i check out god once i
start unwrapping
ah the christmas cutlets
always quiche in our household
um
oh yeah fully by the way i forgot to
mention i i did hire a bunch of dudes to
dress up like cobra kai ninjas to attack
you so you can live out your childhood
fantasy of being an 80s hero by the way
yeah that's pretty good that would be
awesome yeah
and they're going to put a cut off
leather jacket on you before they attack
you
so you look good while doing it
a little a little crazy european escape
room in paris
my girl gets kidnapped i gotta track her
down
i'll probably just move on about my day
to be honest
uh kidding yeah okay let's uh let's get
into some
that their patreon questions uh from the
homies shout out to the homie merry
christmas to the homies and all the
bozos we love all of you love yous
really do
um this one isn't a question this one's
j this is from tommy one year my dad got
my mom a vibrator
that's a tough start to the morning he
orders all his gifts through a catalog
he thought he was ordering a back
massager when it opened it up it fell on
the ground
and we all just that's i mean that's
awesome imagine you that's that's gonna
you can't like then do stockings you
can't do the scratchers you know what i
mean they're your mom's [ __ ]
screaming up in the bedroom
the stockings are stuffed and so is your
mom
yeah what's more awkward that hitting
the floor or her grabbing it
were the batteries included in this
heading upstairs with an extension cord
she takes the batteries out of the
remote
that was awesome kids go make snowman
that was always big the batteries
batteries the day of my mom god lover
always had that [ __ ] ready to go yeah
ready to go yeah there was always i was
like always
because there's nothing worse that's why
i'm playing with the watch yeah once you
get it you want to play what do we do
what are we doing here yeah i once
ruined christmas because christmas what
are you talking about did i um
my brother got something that i didn't
get and i just kept playing with it it
was a little jet and i loved it i was
just playing with it for some reason
the tension between me and him and him
and him fighting over it and this thing
like that that my parents got into a big
fight my dad like took off first you
know like when i have to get some air
and i remember that year my dad gave my
mom the a lionel richie record i can't
remember what he was doing knocking
boots after that
pictures were falling off the wall
and makeup sex was hot
and no vibrator needed up there
big man was taking care of business but
they got into a huge argument my mom was
like upstairs laying in bed just
listening to that record over and over
again and my dad was like out like
shoveling snow geez then they we
eventually came back together that's
what this is about dysfunction and about
crazy
is
it makes the coming back together of the
family that way no you can just stay
together you know now yeah that's insane
you can just be psychos
ruin christmas
that's the best christmas ever i value
it
um all right this one's from daddy oh so
anyone related to a santa at the mall
that's a tough gig that's bad that guy
usually drives a school bus during the
regular time yeah there's always like
peace and stuff oh yeah yeah we had i
i've said it's like a cfl umpire you're
not doing that full yeah that that
that's [ __ ] bad you got it you got a
night gig
um we always used to do um
we we get a we have a big christmas
party uh for the sullivan side of the
family which is like hundreds of people
and we all like i said we get uh santa
and he died last year he would show up
[ __ ]
bombed up at the house no no he would
we'd have to rent a hall in bridesburg
and he would show up and he would show
up tuned out of his mind you run him for
like an hour he comes in
you know wreaking a booze or whatever
and uh
he it's like he's got like the stains in
his beard he's got like his pants are
full you're like dude smells you don't
have much long left smell to a child was
a was a big thing oh that's sig breath
or something yeah that'll burn out burn
in your brain if you were going to
convince me that you were santa claus
yeah you had to smell like cookies or
something like that
i couldn't smell i i couldn't smell the
walk and roll on you that you had for
lunch
at the [ __ ] food court
burping up a lamb burger or something
what is that orange chicken what the
[ __ ] man
uh
just make with the transformers bozo
let's go what the [ __ ]
i didn't as a kid i hate i i loved
christmas i loved santa claus but i was
petra i would didn't sleep
because i didn't like somebody coming
into the house in the middle of the
night
i swear i don't know this guy i know the
easter bunny i would picture the easter
bunny's face just those big teeth like
an eight-foot rabbit in my [ __ ] house
yeah i don't care how much candy you got
i i get that [ __ ] out in the [ __ ]
garage kip let's talk about the guys
over there at the daily tip presented by
bet mgm that's right information as you
know is power
you want to know what's going on rely on
the daily tip to have the best insider
information yeah you need the best
analysis the best of information uh host
michael jenks michael jenkins and
chelsea messenger breakdown big
takeaways to make sure you have
everything you need to bet smarter they
have featured guests such as bookmakers
audacity insiders bet mgm experts you've
always got a fresh take on the action
your friends are wondering where you got
this inside tip yeah you know a guy you
work in a locker room everybody's like
what's going on are you banging a
cheerleader what's happening here where
are they getting this info
um so as much fun as the bet on the game
it's even more fun when you got the
inside scoop are you ready to bet with
an edge tune into the daily tip
presented by bet mgm listen weekdays 6
a.m to 9 a.m eastern on audacity spotify
or your favorite podcast app do it let's
talk about dad grass bad grass talk
about the holidays you know what makes
the holidays nice taking edge off a
little bit taking the edge off a little
bit and not like when you were a kid in
college when you came home and you got
whacked out of your mind and you were
paranoid and you're freaking out and you
thought the quiche was talking to you
and this and that your parents are
sniffing around your room
talking to mature yeah mild
relaxation little toke little puff puff
pass that grass yeah that's what you
want uh there's a lot of uh sweet dreams
are made of cbd baby daggress newest
classic formula cbd tinctures are
perfect at any time but especially for a
great for for a gentle soothing night's
sleep they got the tinctures low you
know [ __ ] bump i know right what are we
dumb over here my hands are let's go
that grass is legal organic i've been
going through those things i know that
grass is legal organic smokable hemp
that relaxes your body and mellows your
mind 100 organic pre-rolled joints are
very low in thc but high in cbd so you
can enjoy the effects of cbd while
keeping your head clear yeah you know
what i mean it's like having a glass of
wine not the whole bottle
all dadgrass products are federally
legal for ages 18 and over and chips
right to your door anywhere in the u.s
of a whether you're looking for a
a new buzz or a way to chill with an old
favorite digress will have you in a
euphoric mood right now dadgrass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dagrass.com garbage
go to dadgrass.com garbage for 20 off
your order one more time write it down
that's dadgrass.com garbage now back to
the show yeah i like i said i called my
dad early on with the presents at like
five or four or something it was like
i'm helping santa i'm like it had to be
early because he was still in that he
was still my mom were still together
that'd be like three i'm helping say
he's like i'm like what are you i'm like
are you that big scotch and soda man huh
i'm a picture of a drink
i'm like what are you doing why do you
have predators i'm helping sand i think
i had already heard rumblings of like
yeah he may or may not be real and this
was like you know cold hard facts i'm
like nah i buy an issue there's a lot of
gossip in the dug out of the little
league games you know well it's like
once you stop leaving insane you don't
also believe in the easter bunny you
know what i mean you don't like still
believe in anything else oh yeah they
fall like western europe
dominoes [ __ ] out yeah
dude the neighbor kid like the bad kid
in my neighborhood i remember we were
standing on the sidewalk he was drawing
swear words in the dirt he was like four
years old
i was like eight years old he looks at
me he just goes sam ain't real by the
way
smoking a sing
he was yeah
sane ain't real [ __ ]
he get off a chopper at nom
go get a pair of your sister's underwear
i want to do a little sniffing
that's [ __ ] funny
um
let's see here
we've talked about this brad g our
lottery ticket's a part of your family's
holiday tradition big at my house
my stepdad will spend about
may 100 bucks on scratchers
for you for for people individuals for
like 100 bucks a person uh i don't know
probably 100 bucks to maybe 200 bucks
total it's like you'll get like one ten
one five and like three ones or ten five
ones okay and like me and my brother
will get the same stack like we'll each
get like a ten a five and whatever
scratch we're not talking about he's not
picking numbers right no we're not doing
the [ __ ] the daily pick four or
whatever now these are these are cold
hard scratchers i won 65 dollars thanks
someone driving to the 7-eleven yeah
i gotta go i gotta go to a 7-eleven in
warminster
anybody going to jersey today
um that's always trashy too bring back
lottery if if the one states got a
hijacked well they they stopped doing
they're all like co-mingled now but back
in the day when the big jackpots the
mega millions was in jersey we used to
drive across for sure to go yeah let's
go to jersey
get a couple of [ __ ] mega milly
tickets grab a clark bar
a couple of newspapers
um yeah scratchers are big big and then
that [ __ ] dust is everywhere you got
a quarter you know get out of time you
get a hot quarter though
yeah gotta get the ridges big ridges
figuring out the game all right i want
two cherries running a gold piece on
leprechaun what's this [ __ ] doing what
i do is even more trashy i just go right
at the bottom to see what you want which
i don't know if they do it anymore oh
yeah i do that i'll go right here i
don't know what's at stake whatever's in
a parenthesis that's what you used to be
the pennsylvania whatever's in the
parentheses yeah this is what you want
because i used to work at the lottery
desk or the photo desk at the acme that
also sold lottery tickets so i'm well
versed in dirt bags you know what i mean
well you know you're very proud you're
very proud of your lottery ticket
salesman days it's discussed a lot about
the rolls when the rolls are hot well
it's all right it's a trash it's not a
classy opera activity so it's all dirt
bags you were kind of like a handicapper
you're you you were like i was like
rusty
[Laughter]
i can tell you whether the delivery
guy's girlfriend was on coke or not
[Laughter]
oh that's great um
all right this one's from fat boy fatty
uh first question kj ever get all banged
up at the family party then go to
midnight mass what was the mass
situation for the foleys uh mass
situation of the folies when we were in
wilkes-barre was midnight man
midnight's whatever did you ever get
hemmed up at a vigil
it's a vigil the vigil candlelight vigil
no for who
they do that like some of the some of
the mit some of the christmas masses are
like the christmas vigils are they
saying that right no i don't think so a
visual vigil you are correct yeah v.i.g
you hold up a candle well it was like a
candle but like also some people like
get their holy communion some people are
getting confirmed it's like it's like an
extreme it's like it's like a catholic
extravaganza yeah the only time [ __ ] my
aunts pray for the only time in my
family anybody was holding up a candle
[ __ ] steve perry was singing i'll
tell you that right now he was belting
out a ballet your mom had her top off
sitting chicken on my dad's shoulder
sit and chicken i love you hey bon jovi
get a little bees
please be 18.
uh i can't it's too buried to my dms to
find but someone dm me uh
do you have to enter the
church address into the gps on christmas
someone sent that to me too that means
that you don't go you you're
you're so far out of the loop ours is at
the end of the block when we lived in
wilkes brain i was a little kid it was
it was smaller it was midnight mass and
then before that we go to mary
catharines and get our little presents
there nice rea it was real qui quiet and
salt not solemn but like you know it was
like it was it felt like the 50s when i
looked back on it yeah you know i mean
up there but then we moved down to
wilkes or to blue i mean it wasn't that
far away but yeah
it was the 80s that'd be like it felt
like it was 2004 to me
that is the 50s well we moved down to
78. when we moved down to the suburbs it
was a mass at like five on christmas
eve
and that was like
that was like
who's seeing who that was checking out
the chicks and and their christmas stuff
you know i mean girls that went to the
catholic school that didn't go to your
school that would be a church you're
checking them out you're in the back
hanging out goofing around with your
cousins getting in trouble yeah yeah we
did that two weeks knocking down hershey
kisses or something on christmas eve we
would all go to my aunt karen's in port
richmond and i think it's like
philly all the churches or at least in
that area all the churches are like um
region like they have like the german
hungarian church the polish church like
all that [ __ ] we would go to the they
would go to the german hungarian church
i think that's what it was or the
ukrainian whatever the [ __ ] it was we
would go
and it'd be like me and like 25 cousins
all from the age of like
14 to 3 horizons and it was just may i
mean dipping out before communion too
yeah i'm not sitting in that parking lot
laughing just the whole [ __ ] night
people running out catch a bernie when
no one's looking type thing yeah it was
nice um that was fantastic
uh
that was christmas eve but then i don't
go anymore i don't i stopped going to
mass a while ago yeah college
whatever i mean what are we doing but
while in college a midnight mass is nice
it's it's fun because you're all like
yeah we're not supposed to be here we
all came together no the incense it's
nice but
especially when you were like freshman
in college or whatever you come back and
you see like all these people that's
what i'm talking about you're like oh
look at that get a little the facts i'm
talking about look at the stems on
blondie yeah no [ __ ] yeah look who
developed huh
you got a nice pair of khakis and a
[ __ ] blue blazer on yeah [ __ ]
killing it
crush you looking sharp yeah i finally
realized what you look like in that
jacket you look like you sell used
christmas cheer
on the 26th
i got two
you look like you visit lonely people on
christmas and try to make them seem like
if everything's okay man that was
working
but it just makes it i might visit that
joke on christmas
and jacob marley yeah
christmas camera
fair enough
what
the panic on your face that people
wouldn't know what you were talking
about christmas carol we all familiar
with dickens work
popular poem all right this one's from
gary ever drink all the milk and he
spelled it milk ever drink all the milk
christmas eve for an excuse to go to the
store christmas day and smoke pot
i'm telling you man
that was big in those days of like oh
you're playing chess not chat you're
you're [ __ ] hey tomorrow for oh
someone's like oh we're out of
taco season all right i'll go i'll go
like no no no don't matter i'll go i'll
go we're at a mustard i'm on it yeah
exactly i'll run to the store don't
worry about it i'm out there [ __ ]
catching heavy heaters yeah
nice
you know that wawa didn't have it i had
to go down the street the super fridge
they didn't have it take a ride take a
toke come back in the christmas spirit
yeah i was always like hey why do you
and danny both have to go to pick up
soda type thing
he's gonna watch a car you know what i
mean
these guys at the bearded shirt and i'm
getting real cute
[Laughter]
need some backup
what would you do hold on i'm holding i
made fun of you you opened did you you
didn't open presents on christmas eve
did you we would open one present on
christmas eve right a little one
yeah i know you had to do it because
your mom was working and all that stuff
but that was when we were older right as
kids it was christmas morning okay like
until like
junior high or how you like all like the
there is people that like christmas eve
is like the the big thing oh then we
sleep in and there's that that what
dolph i can kind like
not if like because i do it but like i
do think there is something a little
more scientist it's the edging that you
like well that's what you like i think
there's it seems like a personal problem
the anticipation uh i do think
i'm gonna open these presents spit on me
first though
somebody hold my nose
now who's gonna call me a [ __ ] while i
open these presents uh because i've been
a naughty naughty boy
you come down on assless chaps
a ball gagging
i'm ready for my stocking stuffers
[ __ ] creepo
um somebody having a candy cane in your
head somebody put on the east german
hardcore looking first
oh yeah um as it like stuff i can
appreciate as an adult
or like even older that there is more of
a at night it's dark out the lights the
lights mean that much more
there's more of an ambiance at night for
sure i'll give you you got the fire
going there's a glow on the lights you
see the neighbor's trees in the dist
throughout the window all that [ __ ]
is better at night there's just
something at night you're having a
cocktail it's it's more
it's more merry it's more cheerful
you're watching seinfeld you got
got friends reruns on
yeah but also what we'll do is we'll
have the bag of trash and then also if
we got a fire cooking we just launch it
in air and torch it jesus yeah
not a whole bunch but enough to be like
all right here we go the bag
the wrapping paper no the wrapping oh
okay you just put the wrap yeah [ __ ]
crumble it off you're throwing plastic
in there no
fuming everybody out who knows everybody
knocks off for a couple days what did
you guys eat christmas morning
uh christmas morning would be like a
spread like you know eggs bacon sausage
maybe some pancakes if that was
preference but typically you know a
standard continental we've discussed the
quiche it was the only thing that we had
and then later on somewhere in the early
2000s
uh a dish became very popular uh among
the garbagio of the time
was the french toast casserole are we
familiar with this no dude it's it's
like chopped it's almost like bread
pudding it's like it's french i never
got that either you're nuts
oh
huge bread is the pineapple involved in
that it could be i'm out really yeah
love pineapple i might be thinking of
pineapple stuffing either way i'm
talking about pineapple upside down cake
with the cherries no i think it's
pineapple stuffing my mom would always
make i don't know about that
i still don't
i've carried it into about 25 christmas
eves i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
i walk into my hand here i remember my
own buddy trying to push carrot apple
raisin salad on me that is mom i don't
even i don't like any of those things
none the four things carrot apple raisin
salad i am out
i got you a nerd parfait yeah
hey hey here's a wedgie
you're gonna get me beat up yeah i used
to push it all the time no bueno uh i'm
not doing that quiche coffee mimosa
bailey's in the coffee yeah bailey's in
a coffee then for sure my brother does
these uh his famous pork roll sandwiches
in the morning
that's a big philly jersey thing pork
roll christmas
oh it's got them lined up just on
regular hamburger buns delish in north
carolina we do country ham and biscuits
fire nice
that's good and roadkill whatever
whatever the catch of the day is
stop by the missile building see what
we're having for dinner
you guys bang your cousins on christmas
or
uh this one i remember from one of my
cousins as a kid which
always made me wonky i don't understand
this is from wren i guess i get it as an
adult a little bit more but from
for christmas does your ex or any ex
still show up to family functions
where they like knocked it they were
like really hit it off with the family
so they show up that kind of they're
stopped by with a present it's real
for any of my exes to want to come to my
christmas god
they wouldn't just have to hit it off
they would have to be
i don't [ __ ] know
in a band together or something like
that
no not at all
that would be awkward
yeah for sure you fat [ __ ]
i didn't know he was going to be here
it's my house
my family always signed it with them
yeah well you stink
fair enough um
no i do think uh i remember my cousin
had this girl and now i think it was
more like an on and off again type thing
on again off against all right i'm
listening yeah
but she would shot and feel like he'd be
like what the [ __ ] like yeah no we're
not together i'm like well then get her
ass shane and a pollyanna all right
i don't want her lowballing me if she
pulls my name
spits taking the value of real estate in
the hoagie deputy you know what i mean
get her out of here that's always weird
another big thing too trashy thing and
we've gotten a bunch from like you know
a lot of repetitive things that i i just
want to touch on um
the putting
a smaller box in a bigger box is bad
like if you're like if i'm giving you a
watch and i put it in a shoebot like put
the watch box it was cool in the 90s
for one time i think oh oh you got me
that type thing yeah [ __ ] kick rocks
yeah yeah [ __ ] teasing me here let's
go that and the secret santa but like
the [ __ ]
stealing the swap trash track it's a
good time to get an uncle mad at you for
sure
for sure that that almost that ended up
that almost ended a couple of [ __ ]
christmases early fighting we did it six
pounds
did it yeah all my aunts the aunts and
uncles did it like all the kids would
sit around and watch and laugh and it
was like what kind of steaks are we
talking about on the table here
i think like 50
thing or whatever you know come on so
somebody would get like you know a nice
that's the booze talking set of steak
knives and somebody get like a blender
they'd be pissed
instead of isotoners or something they'd
be all fed up oh shout out to the
isotoner yeah dan marino sold a lot of
those babies okay guy can move some
leather
not wrong with those things the way they
feel on the steering wheel of a miata
come on oh yeah i think you can only
wear those in a miata james bond
um all right let's see here you're not a
gloves guy are you
no and i saw a guy yesterday who
hit so this really bothered me this is a
little offbeat off topic but it really
bothered me it was two couples in their
late 30s or 30 like no kids
and they were like walking and talking
you could tell it was like a wife
hey we're gonna go for a walk with steve
and cindy type thing
and it was the two wives were in the
front and the two guys were in the back
and it was one guy who didn't want to be
there dressed like normal just like a
picot jeans whatever just like yeah yeah
and the other guy had like the [ __ ]
ski jacket on the neck a hat and ski
gloves walking down like [ __ ]
broadway i'm like 55 things i know i'm
like dude he had the backpack oh he
looked like he was going on a trick i'm
like this guy [ __ ] stinks man if you
that's like you can't do gloves too
early you look like a [ __ ] bozo you
you're fumbling your phone you can't get
the doorknob where will you live now
unless you're unless you're one of the
guys on the trash truck
unless you work for the sanitation
department yeah
you're wearing gloves once or twice a
year yeah if it's like and that's like
and they suck if you're outside a bunch
if you're like oh i'm going to be
outside shovel the side shoulder walk
commuting or something there's no need
keep your hands in your pockets like a
[ __ ] gentleman crazy yeah you [ __ ]
weirdos
take that t-bone
um this one's from uh bernie sanders
you're slowly putting gloves behind your
back
uh this one's from bernie sanders home
run of a name uh do you refer to the
miniature alcohol bottles as shooters or
nips either way is it garbage to get
them as a stocking stuffer
real garbage you get as a stocking
stuffer depends on your age no no no no
age what if it's something classy like
golden schlager or something no there's
no age real gold in there there's no age
where those are classy we refer to them
as airplane bottles we say nips we have
the little nips there's like a little
nip but you take a nip off the top nips
would be the like ponies would be big
like a like a rolling rock the seven
ounce drones yeah
no they're ponies that's the name of
them ponies i think the nips i think
refer to the airplane bottles which are
trap there's
i'm trashy because i find them so fun
i've seen like i'll buy it like if they
have them at the checkout counter i'm
like i'll take duties
when you're a kid and like you go to
transportation when you're a kid you go
to like the wine store in a liquor store
with your mom or your dad when they're
getting [ __ ] for like a party and you'll
see like somebody in line ahead of you
that's getting like a few of them even
as a kid i was like oh this guy's down i
was walking yeah
i was gonna that just happened
when i went to the store
this guy ain't getting skis this year
[Music]
i just just happened uh around the holy
[ __ ] i'm so sorry to interrupt
one year my mom gave my brother water
skis and we didn't own a boat oh my god
what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
have you ever water skied before
yeah
we lived on a lake but across the street
from the lake all of our neighbors had
boats and they were like yeah
that's the saddest [ __ ] i've ever heard
oh thanks
[Laughter]
that stinks getting one ski pole yeah
that's trash
holy that's like
it's like buying somebody's skateboard
wheels without a skateboard
ah here thanks did he ever use them
yeah
in the living room
and the bathtub maybe
get out of here kid was a master of the
green screen that stinks
that's trashy t-bone
water skis are garbage anyway order
schemes trash uh-huh
they always look like they're they're
from the 20s yeah especially the guys
that do it with no skis get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah we used to be uh
there was a while we were a water skiing
family
lake won't paul pack and you're out
there water skiing ice i mean i was a
little fat kid i didn't have the upper
body strength did you ever get up no i
was probably six yeah i've done it like
two or three times never never gotten up
yeah no no never can't even understand
that yeah
yeah it's a lot of upper body strength
that i just didn't i had a lot of i
didn't have much upper body strength had
a lot of lower body weight so it was
tough they kind of counteracted each
other
i was i had a dumper on me
hell of a turd cutter on his kid
kim k jetting around the lake
um all right let's let's run through a
couple of moe here and then we gotta go
it's been a holiday it's been a happy
holiday season yes it has um
let's see
uh
this is from thomas did your parents
ever make you go carolyn around the
corner at christmas time my parents did
it we stunk
they made up i went one time i remember
there was like a group of people in the
neighborhood or whatever like all the
kids were getting it and right away i'm
like i'll hang giving out your mixtape
yo yo yo
i was like i'll go to see what this is
all about but i'm hanging in the back
i'm not storming the beach with you
idiots not being the first man through
the door that guy never makes it and i
hung back we went to like one house i
was like yeah saying
nope i'll be at the i'll be here i'll be
at home with a hot with some coco
cherries in the winter you open up that
door and you smell like their house
smell comes out on the porch like no i
never i don't get that yeah a cowering
caroling no
but uh what an ipod shuffle what are you
doing kick rocks got a sound bar what
are we doing
[ __ ] i'll be bumping this for the
neighborhood i want to listen to some
broader middle school or mr bing crosby
yeah i ever heard of
this [ __ ] um
we would put the candles in the in the
brown paper that's beautiful i do that
for my whole neighborhood yeah i don't
but my
my mom lives in a cul-de-sac you can
tell who the non-believers are
like hey this is a nice block okay
while you play ball
i think there's a johnsons oh they'll be
burning in hell
i think they there there is
i would say it's probably about maybe
half and half by block of my mom's block
of like catholic jewish you know
miss
if the whole neighborhood does you got
to play it everybody does it they were
like hey you know yeah even the heathens
pull together making it look nice make
it look nice um but that's as far as i
still have to do that can you run around
and pick up the bags from nancy on
[ __ ] whatever street yeah i go hi i'm
i'm here to pick up denise's bags oh
it's 20 bucks 20 bucks ooh you should
have coming out of pocket for that a
young terry foley fresh back from nam
[ __ ] trying to put those things
together out front with a [ __ ] half a
case of coors lighting them oh i
wouldn't mind a half a case of course
lightning right now [ __ ] pissed yeah
[ __ ] things god damn it
but i'd never seen a carol or in my life
i only the only time i ever saw one i
was one that wasn't like a piece of like
i worked at macy's in philly they had
that big holiday show which sure sucked
hey the big light show tried to go see
it on on uh sunday when we went down
here really only do it once now 10 30 in
the morning it used to be every hour on
the every hour on the arrow yeah we got
there on a sunday we're like 10 30 in
the morning what are you doing over
there counting his money like at night
we work here
20 40.
i just took i took a picture with the
money and you guys look at all christmas
eve oh i love it happy holidays you
filthy um
angels with filthy souls
this one i don't even get this from
orlando uh my sister used to date a dude
who always stunk so my brother gifted
him a bar of soap for christmas
ouch yeah that's but that's a pretty
good way to be like hey
i don't know i don't think it's lack of
soap that's keeping you smelly nah it's
like axe body you need to see like some
cologne or something
i don't know i don't think
i think if you smell
cologne's not what's he gonna give him a
high-paying job and a place to live what
do you want
what the [ __ ] hey buddy move out from
under the bridge it's not my fault
[Laughter]
here's some pamphlets where you can get
your ged
all right this one's from uh
rattlesnake jake are you the reason your
job no longer has a christmas party
i am not but i technically am this year
oh yeah cause of covid we were supposed
to have a nice christmas dinner tonight
steakhouse take everybody out oh we had
to cancel it yeah
i can still do it uh we had to cancel it
because uh i got the covies but i'm out
of my quarantine
always a little nervous
so also let's trust science you're
boosted i'm outside of the date what are
we doing here kevin's basis on russian
medical medical studies so i was with
both of you we recorded while i had it
what yeah we recorded two episodes that
friday weird
and you didn't get it then i felt my
hybrid
i thought my forehead was getting bigger
i don't like office christmas parties
i don't like
parties with peers family parties are
different okay yeah don't like parties
or peers what i do love what's that is
the next day here and who got [ __ ] up
and who made a fool of himself that was
me and me not being there yeah oh yeah
of course you get all the you have to re
that dude i've said this i think i said
this last time i was at i worked at a
big law firm tammy got hammered and made
out with joe and started crying we did
me and me and some me and some tugboat
did that really yeah it was bad it was
like you know who's christmas party it
was i used to work at this law firm in
philly
really yeah we all went out for like a
happy hour it was like a wow like a bar
crawl oh office happy hour on the
holidays it was it was it was a thursday
night anything good and i'm telling you
that friday during work no one made eye
contact wow there was like 500 people in
the office and no one no one even looked
at it when those poppers and fireball
shots starts going around oh man
hey wanna come back to want to come back
to my
double mattress on the floor lady was i
we living together then
i don't know if we were together it was
that house though really yeah it was
that south philly house nice yeah
you were you were probably in my bed
waiting for me when i got home
just a santa hat on yeah let's uh let's
wrap it up guys what uh you know merry
christmas to both of you merry christmas
fantastic year great year [ __ ] the
army of garbage the homies the bozos
love you so much you have changed our
lives this year it's so [ __ ] cool um
thank you for all the support we you
know we continue you know we vow to
continue to [ __ ] keep cranking out
content
keep trying to uh keep you uh
entertained you know new tour coming
this year new tour coming this year
we're launching we're about to announce
a [ __ ] ton of dates uh
[ __ ] all over this you know florida
denver everywhere we're coming
everywhere tampa denver detroit orlando
atlanta trashy if you say if you say
detroit oh detroit detroit d
i'll be in a d
everybody from the 313. we're looking
forward to it we can't thank you guys
enough honestly i can't thank both of
you enough i love you both very much
thank you for everything uh all the work
that you guys put in this year what a
great thing that we have here and we
appreciate it we love you guys i did
have uh this was kind of a somewhat of a
tradition that you and i used to have
okay i have a uh a toddy's rendition
of twas the night before christmas sure
if we if we'd like to if we'd like to
indulge no i don't really have time to
get it together so well i think you
might be working on it for four hours
before we started so don't [ __ ]
downplay it all right it was the night
before christmas and all through tutti's
house
she was feeling the white claws the
bumps and the bernies as she loosened up
her blouse
she stared out the window
with a lawn chair holding her space
and if someone touches it it'll be a bat
to the face
because the snow had begun to fall on
the solemn christmas night
goddamn omnicron ruined everything and
to be honest cash was a little tight
[Laughter]
kippy and t-bone all snug in their beds
while visions of rogaine manscaped and
the new special danced in their heads
and i with my margarita hot dog in the
eight team on cap had just settled in
for a pre-diabetic nap
when out by the garage we heard such a
clatter totally yelled down one of you
[ __ ] get out there and see what's the
matter
so armed with only a golf club kippy and
t-bone on my back
we tiptoed out in the snow
to give someone a christmas smack
and there in the fridge
helping himself to the miller lights was
a real fat piece of [ __ ] dressed only in
red tights
we rained blowns down upon him
like jerry the stiller kippy moved in
with the screwdriver to take the lead
ooh that kid's a killer
[Laughter]
when all of a sudden t-bone did shout
ah [ __ ] dudes this is santa claus let's
get rid of the body and i'll just step
out
later dude
[Laughter]
but he was a tough old bull probably a
vet
said ain't no man in philly has beaten
me yet he laughed it off with the joke
and told us he was a fan
he said i was just out here collecting
recyclables some bottles and can
we went back to the house and got
hammered until dawn
he went out to meet his dealer
but we knew he was gone
and we heard him exclaim
as he drove out of sight
shout out to the bozos and the homies
these boys are all right and today
looking good still keeping it tight
and a merry christmas to all and to all
a good night